hope is not a strategy when it comes to
security you have to approach security
from all
angles without a lot of burning on dev
or secops not the easiest task
but there's something on google cloud
that can go a long way stay tuned
with an ever-increasing number of
endpoints networks and attack surfaces
setting automated and trickle-down
security policies across your cloud
infrastructure
can be a challenge to say the least on
top of that administrators want to set
guardrails to ensure that their
workloads are always compliant
to their security requirements and
industry regulations
public ips are one of the easiest ways
to expose your enterprise environment to
the internet
so limiting public ips is paramount when
it comes to securing your environments
to do that you need to understand what
resources use public ips in your network
and that can include vms load balancers
and vpn gateways when you start to
deploy production level systems
you're looking at thousands of ways in
which your developers can open public
ipa addresses
this is where organization policies come
into play
org policies give you centralized
guardrail over your organization's
google cloud resources
as the org policy administrator you can
configure restrictions across your
entire resource hierarchy
it works like this you can set org
policies on the org
on folders or on projects they can be
inherited by nested folders and projects
or they can be overridden on a
case-by-case basis
using org policies the org admin can
enforce constraints on google cloud
resources
such as vms and load balancers to adhere
to basic security requirements at all
times
in this video we'll show you how you can
use org policies as guard rails to
ensure
no public ips are allowed in your google
cloud network
it's a perfect tool for it or security
admins to ensure all cloud deployments
adhere
to their security standards let's dive
into how you can limit public ip
exposure
for vms load balancers and vpn gateways
using org policies
compute engine instances can be exposed
to the internet directly when you
assign the vm a public ip or when you
use protocol forwarding with the vm as
its endpoint
to prevent compute engine instances from
getting public ips
first make sure you have the org policy
admin role on the organization
so you can add and edit your policies
then under org policies
search for and edit the org policy
constraint constraints
compute vm external ip access this
constraint lets you define the set of
compute engine vms that are allowed to
use public ips in your network
meanwhile all other vms will not be able
to get a public ip
click edit select customize
replace the parents policy and use these
rules
leave the policy value as custom and set
policy type as allow
then paste the path to the only instance
you want to allow external ipcreation
for
now you've restricted public ip creation
to only this instance
and prevented public ip creation for any
other instances
in your organization to prevent protocol
forwarding from being enabled
use the org policy constraint
constraints compute restrict protocol
forwarding creation 4 types
and set it to the following values note
that the policy value is case sensitive
this constraint lets you limit virtual
hosting of public ips
buy compute engine vm instances in your
organization
for vpns a vpn gateway requires a public
ip address for you to connect your
on-premises environment
to google cloud to ensure that your vpn
gateway is protected
use the org policy constraint
constraints compute restrict vpn peer
ips
this constraint will limit the public
ips that are allowed to initiate
ip's sex sessions with your vpn gateway
next up load balancers google cloud
offers a variety of internal and
external load balancers to prevent the
creation of all external load balancer
types
use the org policy constraint
constraints compute restrict load
balancer creation four types
and then make sure to add all of these
external load balancer types
for the policy values and for ease of
use
instead of manually entering you can
also simply add
in colon external which will always
cover all types of external load
balancers
as new load balancer types are
introduced you can be assured your
infrastructure will remain secure
and finally restricting gke services gke
lets developers create and expose their
services to the internet very easily
but if you add the policies for vms and
load balancers as we showed
no new gke services can be exposed to
the internet without the organization
administrator's knowledge
in this example we've enabled our org
policy constraints
a developer attempts to create a gke
service with an external load balancer
when we check the status of the service
they get a pending external ip
when running cube ctl describe service
they get an error
due to the load balancer or policy
constraint in place pretty sweet
keep in mind org policies are not
retroactive they will only apply to new
infrastructure requests
after the policy is set so you won't
have to worry about breaking any
existing workloads when you add these
policies to your org
and that's it you can apply org policies
easily and efficiently across your
entire
hierarchy or subset of resources from a
single centralized place
you can sleep better at night knowing
you don't have any stray resources that
your teams have assigned public ips to
that shouldn't have them
check out the link below to learn more
and remember optimizing your network
means freeing up
your bandwidth
[Music]
you